[Musique]
soit je crois que je vais rejoindre mon
collègue puisque je suis artiste peintre
et je ne peux commencer sans en citer
nietzsche sans citer nietzsche parce
qu'il n'ya pas de génie d'après lui et
que le génie se forge d'après la société
des besoins de la société
aujourd'hui je suis là pour vous parler
de l'art de l'art dans la nation donc du
romantisme je ne peux je ne peux avancer
sur mon idée si je suis obligé de
revenir un peu sur l'histoire de l'art
et sur le rôle de l'art dans les nations
pour pouvoir avancer à arriver jusqu'aux
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et ce que nous
devenons nous aujourd'hui donc du
romantisme à l'expressionnisme du
symbolisme à la nouvelle objectivité
dollar et howie à l'art dégénéré
c'est parler de l'art dans la nation
c'est parler des courants esthétiques
majeur et fondamentaux s'est parlé d'
artiste visionnaire et révolutionnaire
c'est enfin ouvrir des villes entières
sur le monde
ouvrir son histoire à la fois
culturelles politiques sociales dans
lesquelles les créateurs et les oeuvres
ont été les acteurs incontournables des
tourments et des espoirs des nations
deux nations importantes de nation de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
je ne ne peux pas passer au travers de
ses donations là pour pouvoir avancer
juste dans mon idée l'urss
et l'allemagne nazie totalitaire qui
réplique à un seul mot d'ordre à un
leadership à un parti unique
la propagande a été l'une des premières
armes pour pouvoir faire passer les
slogans les plus importants la programme
la propagande est une stratégie de
communication qui tend à inculquer à
grande vitesse grand v les idées à une
vaste population
le peuple est recadré et renouer dans le
but 2 2 dans le but de de faire passer
une seule idée dans le domaine politique
sociale spirituelle culturelle
nous avons des artistes comme frédéric
comme eux comme comme gaspard comme auto
dicks qui ont été les témoins du
tourment de cette nation nous avons
aussi notre annuaire cesse l'un des plus
grands propagande voilà l'un des plus
grands dictateurs de ce temps-là a été
les mines lui même qui avait prôné le
théâtre et le cinéma pour pouvoir
repousser l'illettrisme dans son pays
je reviens vers nous aujourd'hui
pourquoi pourquoi avoir choisi ces deux
grandes nations
ces deux grandes nations ont utilisé la
culture pour pouvoir avancer la culture
pour pouvoir faire passer leurs plus
grandes leurs plus grandes stratégies
comme ça destructrice
aujourd'hui les choses ont changé mais
ce qui n'a pas changé ce qui a évolué
c'est une espèce d'appareils
extraordinaire de la culture qui s'est
mise en place
en deux siècles
face à nous nous avons singapour
singapour qui est une très grande ville
qui se voulait ou et s'ouvrir vers le
monde
comment s'ouvrir là vers le monde en
créant des théâtres en créant des salles
de spectacle c'est devenu aujourd'hui
une espèce d'esplanade ce qu'ils ont
appelé le plan de la renaissance en 2000
en 17 ans ils ont fait une avancée dans
le dans le monde de l'art contemporain
extraordinaire dubaï dubai comment ne
pas parler de dubaï qui est une plaque
tournante aujourd'hui de l'art
contemporain
dubaï qui est tient une il faut
s'imaginer que c'est une superficie de
3000 825 mètres carrés ou s'il ya eu ou
il ya des môles extraordinaire de
shopping ou les marques se bousculent à
au travers de au travers de dubaï pour
pouvoir être les premiers dubai dubaï
comme plaque tournante de l'art
contemporain oui parce que la
mégalomanie de dubaï se voulait présent
dans l'art contemporain pour la simple
raison que les grands les grandes
figures v ip de ce monde de l'art
artistiques comme le moma de new york
comme le centre pompidou comme les plus
grandes galeries se bousculent pour voir
et pour humer les plus grandes
les plus grandes manifestations et les
et de ceux qui seraient de meilleurs
dans le monde artistique et contemporain
ma question est elle qu'avons nous fait
comment pouvons nous avancer face cette
espèce cette espèce d'appareils
extraordinaire qui s'appelle l'appareil
culturel c'est une machine deux siècles
de préparation deux siècles nous avons
intégré fin nous non mais eux comme
modèle avant ils ont intégré une espèce
de machine extraordinaire pour créer
leur nation de grandes marques
aujourd'hui de très très grande marque
dans le prêt-à-porter cosmétique
l'automobile avance avec le seul
flambeaux qui aimait le luxe
le luxe c'est le maître d'ordre
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir faire passer de
grandes nations par l'emblème de la pure
et de la rareté et le besoin
nous avons créé ce besoin autant qu'être
humain seulement l'algérie est restée en
dehors de cette espèce de mac de
machines nous avons été même pas aux
observateurs
nous sommes où nous avançons nous où
allons nous à mon avis l'aveuglément
dans lequel nous sommes nous irons tous
droit dans le mur
comment pouvons nous prétendre à une
nation aujourd'hui avance en côte à côte
pour pouvoir créer quelque chose qui
s'appelle l'art contemporain aveuglé par
un système qui ne comprend rien à rien
je pense que l'heure est grave
mon travail à moins peut-être qu'on dit
de moi je suis une artiste je ne sais
pas mais tout simplement je suis acteur
et observateur je suis seulement éponge
éponge de quelque chose que j'appelle
l'aliénation
je suis désolé mais l'animation est
présente jusqu'à ne plus pouvoir
regarder le futur vous jeunes vous
adultes jeunes vous adolescents créées
ce système là pour qu'on puisse nous
avancer pour que vous puissiez vous
avancez de toute façon c'est pas vous
qui avancerait mais c'est la nouvelle
génération qui doit avancer nous ne
pouvons occulter ce qui se passe c'est
vrai le postcolonial le colonial afin de
nouer la décennie noire a nous a
beaucoup fait régresser dans le modèle
d'un face aux modèles et aux gérants en
face de nous mais nous pouvons nous
avons une très très belle énergie
nous devons constituer un patrimoine
national quand vous pensez que notre
système
nash est même passé artistique qui sont
dans une précarité extraordinaire
comment voulez vous que nous on continue
à penser à réfléchir à avancer moi je
réponds à des thématiques nous travail
répond avec une thématique le plus
souvent j'essaie de décortiquer une
thématique pour celle ci a été sur le
fil sur le fil
mon à symbolique a été la guillotine
j'ai traversé le temps je suis reparti
jusqu'à 8 14 pour pouvoir comprendre ce
qu était la guillotine
la guillotine a été créée par guy iota
le guide aurait aussi lugubre et macabre
que ça a été guillotiné pensé que
c'était la meilleure façon de tuer de
donner la mort en fait il paraît d'après
guyotat concon s'évanouit et puis la
mort est immédiate
sauf que guetta n'a pas été le premier à
créer cette machine non elle a été créée
dans les pays bas sauf qu'elle a été
importé louis xiv n'a pas n'a pas nacre
n'a pas cru bon en fait utilisé cette
machine et pourtant il est mort deux
c'est avec cette machine vers la
révolution française avec les claude
courte on a abrogé la bourgeoisie
française pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
instaurer une nouveau un nouveau mot
d'ordre qui est le peuple ans j'ai
avancé dans mathématiques
sachant que ce sont deux ans de travaux
et de recherche
j'ai avancé pour aller jusque dans les
jeunes on disait amarok balle vive
l'algérie indépendante
continuant continuons à dire vive
ce n'est pas pour plomber l'atmosphère
mais est ce que nous sommes réellement
indépendant quand j'ai continuer dans
cette lancée pour pouvoir dire
aujourd'hui nous avons en chaque sur
chacun de nous comme l'épée damoclès en
fait une guillotine in guillotine qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas visible puisque
c'est l'ère de l'est du virtuel
elle n'est pas visible elle est
réellement présente je transforme le
langage courant virtuel en langage
plastique
je suis témoin qu'on le veuille ou poids
d'une d'un système témoin d'une histoire
j'ouvre mon histoire à vous pour pouvoir
réfléchir tous ensemble
comment allons nous faire pour pouvoir
avancer le mot d'ordre doit être avancée
nous devons avancer sinon nous allons
tous droit dans le mur
voilà
[Applaudissements]